people
you want to let them crush us into some
capital city is that it oh come on is
that what you think's gonna happen
I have no idea about that obviously I'm
not gonna wait and find out am I
so
what are you gonna do you're gonna just
attack him no one's asking you to join
in you'll get yourself killed
if you've not got the balls
all you have to do is say establish
devices
[Music]
thank you
water
people down sorry
still no sparkling
I'm okay
if it was a do nothing
believe me I won't turn on your reading
light
you're good
[Music]
take one thank you pass it down water
anyone
[Music]
what's up
just go watch this is Mars we're
official with a figure of mid fuselage
stand by
ing contact this female age around 30
3-0 contact is being attacked
I do not communicate
we need someone to land the plane
we're flying over hungry we used to be
hungry I mean yes yeah yeah we need to
persuade the hungarians to let us land
this
Hungarian Air Traffic Control speak
English I know don't eat Hungarian
we do because
because don't
so if you can get a message down to them
in Hungarian this could all be over
which one was it
it was me
thank you
you talked